the people already want to watch the
show
that isn't good enough they have got to
be so
scared to miss it so terrified here's
the kind of thing i would have done
grace queue it up
you are a disgrace
drug addict potentially closeted lesbian
you've never moved out of the house
nobody respects you you are
probably you are gross around kids
you're a weirdo they gotta watch you
like pepsi
so don't keep my name out of your mouth
okay
drug addict because if i bumped into him
i'd really give him a piece of my mind
how are you gonna bump into me i don't
live in your kitchen
okay
you've never left
i'm in malibu oh how am i gonna bump
into you
it's not bad huh